[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris berman espn
nfl primetime co-host and uh 2010 pete
roselle radio tv award from the pro
football hall of fame
championship sunday coming up this
weekend
chris and keyshawn johnson will air on
espn at 10 eastern that will be
following the bills and chiefs also nfl
prime time divisional playoff shows
available now through uh saturday night
uh on espn espn plus as we welcome in
the hall of famer chris berman chris how
are you buddy
dan good to be with you man you're
you're still somebody i was somebody
it's a proud it's a pleasure to break
some bread with you on
championship week what's the oddest
place you've been recognized
because of your voice oh
because of voice only well i mean i go
to a lot this year right when you have
masks on right and you're in the
supermarket let's say that's not the
oddest but this is the most recent of
all the time
and you know you're alone you're not
saying anything but then
when you speak up like two people in a
line at the checkup oh wait a minute
is that you i said geez i had a mask on
like that didn't
not that i'm running away from anything
um
voice
this is going way back now because it's
kind of the answer you want if i forgot
in all the years
you and i and we're traveling and flying
and going to airports and connecting
blah blah blah
if i forgot if it was summer or fall
if i'd go to let's say o'hare right and
i'd hear
in july kind of under everyone's breath
back
you know when i look around and i didn't
see anybody oh it must be summer
baseball
and then you know in the fall
you'd hear anything from rumble or the
raiders
or you could go up and then i look
around and
where are they that nobody's looking at
me oh yes that's right it's football
season so
they just yell it out they see you
walking and uh yeah
yeah no need to bother you they
acknowledge you by by just
throwing out something i smile why not
my goodness if we're on like you and i
as long as we've been on and no one
knows
what we've done or what we what we do
then we we've
kind of failed right i guess how did you
become a bills fan
i'll try not to make this too long the
first part of the equation is the afl
okay dan so i grew up at j stadium uh
with the jets uh dad season tickets two
young boys nine and seven
sixty four they moved to shea stadium
the world's fair
we got tickets name at 65 etc
the bills as a nine and ten year old
were the first
champ of my league so you know as you're
a young kid you know who's like good and
who's not
right so there was a soft spot from then
they were the first champs that i
remember and oddly enough
um they could have played in the first
super bowl if they had won
three in a row but the chiefs beat them
and that's just a little i mean there's
nothing to do with
sunday but it's a little footnote um
and then fast forward which we you and i
probably talked about in the days and i
used to go to a lot of training camps 10
12 of them you know one day here one day
there sound like baseball i mean you're
traveling blah blah
it was the last of 12 teams that i saw
at 88 and i'm not bill polley and i'm
not i'm not anyone i can't stand on the
sideline and tell you in a day what you
have
but this team looked like the best um
that i saw and they were seven and eight
the year before
and here's jim kelly throwing and rookie
thurman thomas and
bruce smith was the number one pick and
cornelius bennett they traded for and
andre reid at setter
i picked them for the super bowl there
and i just you know i
i am the swami i throw things out there
some of them stick right and and now
they did get to the championship game
office sev
everyone said what are you nuts they
started 4-0 etc
well i went up to cover them and i know
this is an answer longer than you want
but i went up to cover them
before their first playoff game which
was against houston and glanville
not the frank wright game but another
one and um well frank
uh glenville wasn't coaching them in
that game but
i i get ready to leave to go back to the
airport and get to the airport at
whatever 7
30 for the flight to hartford and um
there's a couple tv cameras there's bill
paulian there's the mayor or or the
first city councilman i forget exactly
and they hastily like stopped me and
present me the key to the city
now all i did was predict their football
team yeah
but the folks in buffalo as you know
you know they're they're national
punchline oh it's no
you know and and and
the fact that i just supported their
football team
they wanted me to know that i was one of
them
and so you can't turn down that kind of
love and my 41 years at espn i mean
that's
as far as you know fan base from afar
i mean that that's something that it's
it's rewarded me to this day
but of course with that team i mean we i
keep in touch with all of them but did
you catch any grief from management at
espn that
you were i guess openly rooting for
a team i mean you had fun with it but
you were
nobody circles the wagons like the
buffalo bills you also
you know love the niners as well i
didn't know if management said
let's try to be unbiased here well
i i don't think i was biased i'm allowed
to pick whoever i want right like and
then if i start to be
2 and 20 you better analyze it well i'm
going with the bills well they lost by
30 again you idiot you know
so no because i i didn't feel i was
walking the line dan
first of all in those years
all of us had teams as long as it and i
rarely got accused and i think this is
this is true i know it's true of
if it as long as it doesn't shade what
you see
or what you say they play the game well
they were
the reps they screwed they'll stop and i
don't think it ever did
i i tried very hard to make sure that it
never did
to this day and
it also was helpful the san francisco
was kind of a non-fought
the niners until they won with montana
they were not a national team at all
as it turns out you know i wasn't piling
on the dallas cowboys or the
pittsburgh steelers or the new york
teams the teams i kind of
adopted as it turned out were kind of
the corners of the country where
they didn't have national voices like
buffalo i know it's not the corner but
just bear with me
uh early on dan tampa you remember
right um certainly san diego
uh and seattle well those weren't so
these were teams that
there wasn't an abundance of national
quote
voices for them but as long as it
doesn't
affect your ability to be honest i don't
think
anybody who's a sports fan can hold
against
you like some teams more than other i i
that nothing's changed in my in my all
my years there
what would your approach be if you were
just starting out
now with espn as opposed to when you
were there in the embryonic stages
good question um
well i would hope i had the hair that i
had
i think i saved some pillows somewhere
but i i can't put my hand on it right at
the moment dan
but um
[Music]
not unbelievably different because i
think deep down our job is to get it
right to convey the information
i think that well my excitement is real
i mean you know me personally i'm kind
of the same way that doesn't mean that i
shout down every aisle of the
supermarket but um
i i think enthusiasm uh when it's
genuine is appreciated whatever job you
do whether it's uh um
digging ditches or or whether we're on
tv doing sports which is a little easier
to be enthusiastic about and
and and i think as long as you are
yourself
i think those three things i mean i
would tell any young sportscaster radio
tv you're hopeful to do those things
don't be enthusiastic if if you're more
of a bob lee type
it's not to say that bob didn't enjoy it
but he's
different than me or you and and i have
the utmost respect for bob obviously to
this day
so i i don't think in that re at the
very
base of starting out dan um
that there would be that much difference
those
catchphrase you know the the things that
are nicknames etc
i never did those to be hey
i can be famous because that doesn't
work in the long run
so those three things i i still would be
the same in that way now obviously
medium and everything has changed some
um but we would adapt to whatever
technologies are now versus then or
etc i i think you probably if someone
asked you that you'd be pretty
similar answer i i would think so well
they they didn't want us to be ourselves
and and you probably ran into this as
well that certain
management members didn't want you to do
those nicknames
or be yourself keith and i faced that
same kind of barrier there there was a
glass ceiling that we didn't realize
and then when we did it was probably too
late nowadays
you know they're begging for talent to
be
hey go in there and have fun be big be
you know
don't don't be afraid whereas we tiptoed
late at night and i'm sure you probably
had your moments where
you had somebody who said hey can you
cut out the nicknames here
well i did and we don't need to go into
that story they did at the end of a
baseball season in 85 and they were back
in 86 and
and he was gone so they fought the law
in the law
[Laughter]
about the charlotte observer when i
first got there
and and i i was for some reason
i had to observe the making of
sportscenter for i think at least two
months
and you just saw me come in i'd sit down
i wouldn't say anything i would just
watch you guys write sportscenter and
then i
every day i walked in and you went the
charlotte observer
and i i just said my wife would say how
does it go and i said
oh chris berman calls me the charlotte
observer i said i don't know if he likes
me or not but he calls me the charlotte
observer and she goes
uh okay and then i explained it to her
but yeah and then my first show was when
chris
stayed after doing the 11 o'clock and he
stayed for my first one so
forever indebted as he went on and
helped the charlotte
observer so i'm to blame huh
whatever happened yeah you you helped me
listen but just quickly to get a chuckle
out of you
the beauty was my style was it not to
mean that
anybody at any moment couldn't say you
know cut it you know
pipe it down or cut it out or or tone it
or change it
the beauty of figuring this out in the
80s is
we i don't know who was watching in the
very early stages now
i was a little not wild we didn't crack
eggs on our heads
we were all into sports but four years
dan i did the 230. now
that's 11 30 on that west and you know
earlier in hawaii but
but high
tape was expensive maybe the bosses will
never see it
so so a lot of how i was established was
a decade ahead of you at least at our
place i mean you were at cnn etc but it
it's not to say oh well he's already
this we can't change his batting style
you know the way he throws the ball sure
you can because we if we can't improve
we're going backwards but i
you know some people were using us as a
nightlight early on
and that's when i kind of established on
the air
and kind of lurching forward and
backwards
who i would eventually become i i had
that advantage there was nobody
observing us
all right uh in 60 seconds which is
impossible for you
yeah correct tell me what's going to
happen in both title games this weekend
well we'll start with the chiefs because
as we speak we don't know if mahomes is
playing and for us to guess
i mean i think he will but that's not
the chief's hiding information right
yeah
um i
think if he plays and he you know is
pretty i think we have
you know we didn't get the games last
weekend we thought we would as far as
you know points etc i think that's a
28-24 somebody um
fun and the other one
[Applause]
wow can you pick against tom
but he and gronka played in the cold but
i don't know about a lot of others
aaron rodgers is on such a level that
tom will have to be his very best which
he's certainly capable of doing
to be that's another 28 24-ish
um notice i'm hedging you are
well which is on the swami like um
i would lean to the packers and on the
first one i'm so close with both
teams you know andy reed and me um
a big part of me would like the bills to
get to the super bowl and then my god
are they going to be staring at tom
brady
20 years like oh oh no not him
or or will the chiefs have that rare
opportunity dan to be a repeat
champ and that doesn't come around a lot
and i they're at home i
i give the edge to the two home teams as
we speak at this moment
great to talk to you as always i hope
you're uh hope you're doing well and
having fun i am the prime time on reel
tv
espn the original you know before they
changed the cans
and uh good to talk to you paul best
best home okay
thank you chris that's uh chris berman
the espn nfl
primetime co-host and uh member of the
pro football hall of fame